اهلا بكم مشاهدينا العربيه مستمره في هذه
التغطيه لتطورات الاوضاع في السودان حيث
لا تزال الاشتباكات مستمره في ولايات
مختلفه في السودان بين قوات الجيش طبعا
والدعم السريع بعد ان وصلت المحادثات الى
طريق مسدود بين الطرفين الطرفين اتفقا على
شيء واحد وهو ان هذه الاشتباكات ستنتهي
سريعا لكن المشهد على الارض لا يوحي
بنهايه قريبه حيث يعلن الجيش استسلام قوات
من الدعم السريع في مواقع مختلفه اضافه
الى قصف معسكراته فيما يتحدث الدعم السريع
من جانبه عن سيطرته على قواعد عسكريه في
الخرطوم وفي غيرها من المناطق السودانيه
كما اعلنت عن اغلاق كل المنافذ جنوب
العاصمه الخرطومه ووسط كل هذا تدعو معظم
دول العالم رعاياها الى الالتزام باماكنها
وعدم الخروج في المناطق المفتوحه خصوص ا
بعد ان علقت معظم شركات بل علقت معظم
شركات الطيران العالميه رحلاتها الى
الخرطوم بشكل مؤقت حتى تتكشف نتائج ما
يحدث اليوم
وهذا واعلنا المركز الاعلامي للخطوط
السعوديه عن تعرض طائره ايرباس تابعه
للشركه لحادث في مطار الخرطوم الدولي قبل
اقلاعها للرياضه واوضح المركز انه تقرر
تعليق جميع رحلات الشركه من والى السودان
حتى اشعار اخر مؤكده ان فرق العمل بالشركه
تعمل مع كافه السلطات ذات العلاقه وعلى
راسها سفاره السعوديه لدى السودان للحصول
على مزيد من المعلومات حول الحادث
قال رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في
السودان الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان في
تصريحات للعربيه ان المتمردين من قوات
الدعم السريه سعوا للسيطره على مقرات
الجيش والمناطق الحيويه فجرا واضاف
البرهان ان متمردين دعم السريع خططوا
لتنفيذ اغتيالات وان خيار الجيش الوحيد هو
التصدي لمطامع من وصفهم بالمتمردين في
السلطه قال عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش
يدير عمليات ضد المتمردين بصدر لمنع وقوع
اي خسائر بشريه مؤكدا ان الجيش السوداني
لديه قوات كافيه واراده لبحر هؤلاء
الاشخاص
وقبل ان نتابع ان نذكر بان هناك استمرار
لدوي اطلاق النار في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وكنا تابعنا في بدايه هذه الساعه
الاخباريه
للاوضاع في الخرطوم وسمعنا اطلاق النيران
ما زال مستمرا هناك بعد الانتفاضه الشعبيه
مشاهدينا التي اطاحت في ابريل عام 2019
بحكم عمر حسن البشير بدا السودان مسيره
التحول الى الديمقراطيه لكن عراقيل مختلفه
وقفت في الطريق في ظل الصراع المحتدم على
السلطه في هذا البلد نتابع
السودان رحله شاقه من البحث عن الحريه
والديمقراطيه حكايه طويله لم تكتب لها
نهايه سعيده حتى الان
الان كم من ذلك ان هذا البلد العربي
والافريقي انزلق نحو القتال بدل لغه
السلام والحوار
التحول نحو الحكم المستقر مثل شعله امل
حين تمت الاطاحه بنظام البشير عقب انتفاضه
شعبيه في ربيع العام 2019 في اغسطس من
السنه ذاتها وافق الجيش على تقاسم السلطه
مع المدنيين ريثما يتم اجراء انتخابات لكن
الترتيب تعطل وسرعان من قلب على ما التزم
به الزي العسكري في السودان وكحال اغلب
بلدان الجنوب يشكل قوه مهيمنه منذ
استقلاله عام
1956 اذ خاض حروبا داخليه وقام بانقلابات
متكرره ولديه حيازات اقتصاديه ضخمه حظي
الجيش بدعم داخلي من فصائل متمرده استفادت
من اتفاق السلام في 2020 ومن المخضرمين في
حكومه البشير الذين عادوا الى الخدمه
المدنيه الصراع بين قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
الب ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو يوازيه صراع
اخر مع المدنيين الذين يضغطون من اجل
الرقابه على الجيش ودمج قوات الدعم السريع
شبه العسكريه التي لها وضع قوي في الجيش
النظامي امر اخر يدخل في المعادله السودان
موجود في منطقه مضطربه يحدها البحر الاحمر
ومنطقه الساحل والقرن الافريقي استقطب
موقعه الاستراتيجي وثرواته الزراعيه قوى
مختلفه ما ادى الى تعقيد فرص نجاح
الانتقال وها هو الان في طريق حرب اهليه
ستعيده سنوات الى الوراء بلال الوجداني
العربيه
ونتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور لمروحيه
تابعه للجيش السوداني تقصف مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع خلال هذه الساعات التي بدات
فيها
الاشتباكات بين الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
مبروك والله مبروك
مبروك الله مبروك والله
[موسيقى]
اكثر على ما يجري على الارض في الخرطوم
ينضم اليه الان مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا في بدايه هذه
النشره كنا تابعنا صورا من الخرطوم وكنا
نسمع اطلاق النار ذوي اطلاق النار كيف
يبدو الجو الان
وهل هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت على نفس
الوتيره
نعم بعد هدوء الى النسبي عما العاصمه
الخرطوم اثناء لحظات وساعات الافطار
اخر
ربع ساعه من النهار وحتى بعد الافطار بنصف
ساعه تقريبا كانت الاوضاع هادئه الان بدا
يسمع ذوي اغلاقنا بحري في هذه المناطق
التي نحن نتواجد فيها الان فيها انقطاعم
للتيار الكهربائي منذ ساعات في اول النهار
والثانيه عشره الان ندخل على الساعه
السابعه او الثامنه انقطع هذا السياره
الكهربائي سالم
انقطاع يعني في اغلب مناطق العاصمه ليس
كامل لكن في اغلب مناطق العاصمه
كثير من المناطق التي اتصلنا بها اكدوا ان
هذه القطاع موجود لديهم في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم هنا ظلام دابس مع هذا
الظلام نشاهد السنه اللهب والدخان في
المناطق التي يسمع فيها ذوي هذا
واطلاق هل من معلومات سالم اين تتركز هذه
الاشتباكات اطلاق النار هل هو في مواقع
معينه معروفه ما هي هذه المواقع
اغلب هذا الاخلاق الكثيف للنيران
والاحتدام الموجود او الاشتباك الموجود في
المنطقه المركزيه في الخرطوم وحيض القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني كذلك كما قال
الخرطوم الدوليه قصر الجمهوري هذه المناطق
هي الاكثر يعني يسمع فيها دليل الرصاص
وتبادل الكثيف لاطلاق النار كذلك هنا في
بحري في الجسر الرابط بينهم برمان وبحري
جسر الشمات في في طرف الجسر هنا في بحر
ايضا يسمع اطلاق للرصاص تبادل لايرانانيه
في هذه المنطقه ايضا هنا في بحث
سالم ايضا بالنسبه
للمدنيين هناك انباء عن سقوط ضحايا وايضا
عن جرحى هل اي جهه رسميه الطبيه تحدثت عن
الاعداد عن وضع هؤلاء الجرحى عن اعداد
الضحايا
هناك لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه تحدثت
عن عشرات القتلى وكذلك
الجرحى في مختلف ولايات السودان توردوا
الى المستشفيات المختلفه ولم
اكدت ان هناك صعوبه في ايصال مساعدات
تتعلق بالادويه وكذلك الطبيه التي تعين
على اسعاف هؤلاء المدنيين الاحصائيات في
ازدياد حتى يعني الى الان لا توجد احصائيه
دقيقه تماما لان هذه الاعداد تتزايد على
راس الساعه كل مره يتم الوفود الى
المستشفيات باصابات مختلفه
في مختلف في مختلف ولايات السودان ليست
الخرطوم وحدها فحسب هناك مقاطع متداوله
وموجوده في السوشيال ميديا عن ضحايا فلبيط
في الطرقات من المواطنين كذلك في مرو من
غيرها يعني يوجد العديد من المناطق التي
يوجد بها اعداد من الضحايا والاصابات كذلك
مدينه الفاشر شهيده اعداد عديده من
الضحايات الناس عن مئات حتى لكن الى الان
لا توجد احصائيه دقيقه بشكل واضح عن عدد
الضحايا في الولايات المختلفه اسمح لي ان
تبقى معي سنتابع مشاهدينا واياكم هذه
الصور المتدا وله لاثار الدمار في مطار
الخرطوم جراء الاشتباكات التي حصلت بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
سالم ما اعود اليك هل هناك من مواقف جديده
تتحدث عن مبادرات معينه ان كان من الاحزاب
المتواجده في السودان ان كان من المكون
المدني هل هناك من اي جهود جديه بدات
الى الان كل الجهود التي بذلت هي تصريحات
للمجتمع الدولي في اكثر من
مكان هناك تصريحات مختلفه تحدثت عن الدعوه
لاحكام صوت العقل لكن جاء الرد على كل هذه
المبادرات حتى
المبادرات التي تسالين عنها بالنسبه للقوى
السياسيه وكذا كلها الان الجيش السوداني
قد تحدث قبل قليل على انه لن يكون هناك
حوار او تفاهمات او اي وقت في اطلاق النار
حتى
ينتهي التفلت داخل الدعم السريعه وحتى
ينهي التسلطات داخل الدعم السريع هذا بشكل
قاطع وواضح كان في تصليح الجيش السوداني
هذا بالمقابل ايضا هناك
يعني بالنسبه للتحركات على الارض نجد ان
هناك انباء كثيره عن مناطق سيطر عليها
الدعم السريع ومناطق استعادها الجيش
السوداني تتفاوت هذه الانماء بشكل وباخر
طبعا على الارض سالم ماذا تلاحظون ما
هي الطرفين تتوجه نحو الخرطوم هل تشاهدون
ذلك ام لا
نعم هو بالفعل التعزيزات والحركه صعبه جدا
لان الخرطوم الالي حتى تكوني في الصوره لا
يوجد بها احد يتحرك الان مع هذه الايرانيه
العاليه مع هذا الاشتباك العالي حتى الناس
وهم في بيوتهم هناك اصابات يعني كبير من
هذه الاصابات كانت داخل المنازل من
المدنيين لذلك الحركه في الشارع غير
موجوده على الاطلاق للمواصلات
حتى المواطنين كل المواطنين في بيوتهم
اشبه بحضره تجوال الذي فرض بصوت البندقيه
فرض عليهم مساله حضره تجوال بان لا تكون
هنالك حركه فصعب جدا مثل هذه الامور كل ما
يسمع ويرى في الشارع وهو هذه الاعراض
الناريه هو تبادل الاصوات
المدفعيات الثقيله استخدام الهاون حتى
قذائف كل هذه تم استخدامها في الخرطوم هنا
وفي الساعات الماضيه طب بالنسبه للمواقع
الرسميه سالم
القصر الرئاسي التلفزيون السوداني هل
تاكدت مثلا من يسيطر عليها الان بعد
هناك ايضا انباء وردت الى انه الدعم
السريع اعلن سيطرته على سلاح المهندسين
بمدينه ام درمان واللواء 21 بولايه شمال
دارفور هذا ما ورد من انباء عن
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع وامتداد نفوذها
سلاح المهندسين هو في مدينه ام درمان بعد
جسر الفتحات مباشره احد الاسلحه المهمه
للجيش السوداني تحدث الان الدعم السريع
على انه سيطر عليها بالنسبه لهيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون ايضا سيطرت عليها قوات الدعم
السريع وسيطرت على دبابات ايضا موجوده
داخل مباني الاذاعه والتلفزيون
واخلي مباني الاذاعه والتلفزيون حتى ضرب
الاستديو الرئيسي للاخبار في مبنى لدعوه
التلفزيون والان يتواجد في المبنى فقط
مهندسين للبث
وذكروا لنا بانهم لم يتعرضوا او لم تتعرض
لهم القوات التي داهمت المباني والمباني
الاذاعه والتلفزيون من الدعم السريع وانما
ذكروا لهم انه مجبرين على هذا الامر وهم
الامر متواجدون في داخل مباني الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
هكا حتى الان سالم الهاشمي دائما سنكون
معك على اي تطور في الخرطوم
الاشتباكات اذا مشاهدينا متواصله بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع التي
اعلنت سيطرتها على مطار الخرطومه كيف نشات
قوات الدعم السريع وكم يبلغ تعدادها نتابع
[موسيقى]
دعا وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان الاشقاء في السودان لسرعه وقف
العمليات العسكريه وضبط النفس واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي في سلسله تغريدات على
تويتر الاطراف السودانيه لتجنب التصعيد
وتغليب مصلحه شعبهم كما دعا الاطراف
السودانيه الى العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطالي للتوصل لحل سياسي لتحقيق الامن
والاستقرار للبلاد
اظهر مقطع فيديو سيطره الجيش السوداني على
معسكر كيري في ام درمان التابع لقوات
الدعم السريعه
يا ساتر
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
ما كان امس صراعا على السلطه بين مكونين
عسكري ومدني اليوم نزاعا على السلطه نفسها
بين جنرلين نسف مقولات قوه واحده على قلب
رجل واحد التي رددها سابقا رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
فحمتي لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب نتابع
امبراطوريتان عسكريتان قامتا على انقاض
حكم البشير رجلان الحكم العسكري في
السودان نفايا مرارا وجود اي خلاف بينهما
وحجم التراشق الكلامي في خانه حرب زائفه
ابتدعت اعلاميا بهدف خلق الصف الواحد الا
انه منزلق للمواجهه المسلحه
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد القوات البريه في
عهد البشير صار قائدا للجيش النظامي فيما
اسست ثاني اي محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحميتي قوات الدعم السريع معتمدا
عالميليشياتا خاضت حربا داميه في دارفور
لكنه لم يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في
الدوله او النائب
تهديد فعلي شكله احمدتي للبرهان معززا
امبراطوريته بجيش خاص قوامه 100 الف عنصر
اي ما يوازي تقريبا حجم قوات الجيش
السوداني فضلا عن تكسب اقتصادي نتج عن عقد
صفقات مع شركات دوليه
في الاتفاق الايطالي اداه للمحافظه على
مكتسباته لكن التوقيع فشل مرتين بسبب
خلافات حول دمج قوه الدعم السريع في الجيش
ومداه الزمني ووضعيه قياده القوات ففي حين
اراد البرهان اتمام الدمج وفقا لقواعد
الجيش وانظمته تمسك احمدتي باعاده هيكله
قياده الجيش العليا اولا حتى يكون جزءا
منها قبل دمج قواته وتقليص نفوذه نازل
احب
قدام احسن نمشي
قضايا خلافيه اخرى شقت طريقها الى
المنظومه الامنيه مثل اصلاح الجيش وابعاد
انصار النظام السابق عنه كما مثلت اداره
الملفات الخارجيه ونسج نائب البرهان
لعلاقات عابره للحدود تحديا كبيرا
للجانبين فحمل التي متهم من قبل الجيش
بخلق علاقات دبلوماسيه موازيه للدوله
متابعه ايضا لهذه التطورات ينضم الي من
الخرطوم دكتور رشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه في مركز العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم كما ينضم اليه
ايضا امام الحلو رئيس لجنه السياسات في
حزب الامه القومي اهلا بكما دكتور ابدا
معك هل نحن امام خلاف وصراع على السلطه
اما هناك امور غير معلنه لا نعرف ما هي
اهدافها
شكرا على الاستضافه طبعا لا يمكن استدعاء
صراحه حول السلطه من الاحداث الحاليه
باعتبار ان
الخلاف هو خلاف سياسي حول رؤيه لمستقبل
العمليه السياسيه في السودان ولكن الخلل
الذي حدث والذي ارتكبته قوات الدعم السريع
هو في انها استخدمت
السلاح والقوه لتحقيق هذا الهدف
والخروقات التي
بدات حر تحريك القوات من دارفور والتجنيد
ومن ثم تحرير قوات الى مروي دون تنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه هو الذي اعرض تصنيف قوات
الدعم السريع بانها قوات لم تعد حليفه كما
كان في طيله الفتره السابقه
تتحدث عن لم تعد حليفة ولكن اليوم سيد عبد
الفتاح البرهان
بانها عدو اعتبرها بانها اشخاص متمردين
يعني هناك عده تسميات اصبحت او صبغت اليوم
للدعم السريع ايضا هناك خبر عاجل قبل ان
اتابع معك اتصال ثلاثي بين وزراء خارجيه
السعوديه الامارات وامريكا لبحث الاوضاع
في السودان ايضا الجهود الدوليه ما زالت
مستمره الان نتحدث عن اتصال ثلاثي بين
الامارات السعوديه
وامريكا لبحث الاوضاع في السودان
اعود اليك دكتور يعني موضوع حلفاء الامس
اليوم نتحدث عن عداء اليوم نتحدث عن
ميليشيات
ايضا اطلق على الدعم السريع من قبل الجيش
السوداني وقادته بانهم ميليشيات هل نحن
امام
يعني لا مجال للعوده الان للتهدئه بعد كل
هذه التصريحات والتصعيد الكلامي بين
الطرفين
نعم حتى اكمل فكرته انا ذكرت انهم كانوا
حلفاء الامس ولكن التصرف الاخير هو صنفهم
ضمن القوات المتمرده والخارجه على القانون
والتي تسعى للسيطره على الحكم لانه عندما
تتحدث عن تسيطر على مواقع استراتيجيه
السؤال البديهي ماذا تريد او ما هو هذه
السيطره فبالتالي يبغى الصراحه حول السلطه
وصراع السيطره هو حاضر في هذا المشهد الشق
الاخر من سؤالك
نضع نحن تجاوزنا مرحله
المفاوضات والتصالحات والوساطات
لانه كانت هذه مفيده قبيل الاندلاع ولكن
بما ان الحرب اندلعت ووضع المحظور نحن
امام واقع جديد اتوقع انه يعني لن تكون
هنالك وساطه
قيمه ما لم تنجلي هذه المعركه والتي تحدث
دعني دكتور اذهب الان الى السيد امام
الحلو لايضا نطلع منه كيف يمكن ان ينتهي
هذا الامر كيف يمكن ان ينتهي هذا التصعيد
ليعود للكلام السياسي والدبلوماسيه ان
تدخل على الخط مجددا استاذ امام
شكرا جزيلا قناه العربيه نحن اليوم في
موقف حزين جدا وفي موقف عصيب
ضرب البلاد كلها وليس في الخرطوم فقط ولكن
في مدن رئيسيه في السودان
الان كان الخلاف حقيقه
لسبب الاحتقان بخلاف فني في الفتره الورشه
الاصلاح الامن والعسكري
وتحول الى
صراع عسكري والان اليوم نشهد
التحول الى صلاح سياسي ثم تحول الى صراع
عسكري
وسبب بان السيد حمدتي لن يقبل بعد اليوم
ان يكون الرقم اثنين او النائب
نحن لا نتحدث في هذه التفصيلات لانه الان
حدثت مواجهه عسكريه بين طرفين الشقاء نحن
كنا نتعامل معهم على اساس مكونه عسكري
واحد
وتوقعنا معهم اتفاق اطاري على اساس
ترتيبات معينه الى احلال
السلطه الى مكونات المؤسسات انتقاليه
مدنيه وكان ده الاتفاق وحتى الان نحن
نتعامل مع الطرفين متنازعين كمكون عسكري
وهم الاثنين ابناء الوطن
وما في اي فرصه
لوقف هذا النزيف الدموي الا عبر الحوار
والتحلي بالصوت الحكمه
في ظل هذا التصعيد العسكري بين الطرفين
بين داخل المكون العسكري الواحد
العمليه السياسيه هي المعنيه بالمسار
السياسي لانهاء الانقلاب العسكري اللي هم
شاركوا فيه والطرفين
والتاسيس المؤسسات
السلطه الانتقاليه المدنيه وده نحن في
القوه السياسيه
مصممين على ان هذه العمليه السياسيه كما
ينبغي وهذه العقبه الان هي عقبه علينا ان
نزعه جميعا بالحكمه وقف اولا وقف
المواجهات العسكريه التي راح ضحيتها
من قادر على وقف هذا التصعيد من وقف على
تجاوز هذه العقبه
المؤول الاول على القيادات العليا البرهان
وحمتي
الاحتكام الى صوت الحكمه
والحصه الوطني اللي موجود في كافه القوات
السودانيه
لابد من وقف هذا النزيف ولا بد من وقت
اطلاق النار فورا ونحن نطالب قوه سياسيه
سودانيه والشعب السوداني نفسه يطالب بوقف
هذا
المواجهه العسكريه الان ثم الاتفاق حول
كيفيه معالجه الاختلافات الموجوده اذا كان
هي اصلا اختلافات فنيه او حتى اختلافات
قياديه على ايضا دعنا ونحن نتحدث معك
استاذ امام هناك اخبار عاجله ايضا مصدر
عسكري يتحدث بانه لا صح لسيطره الدعم
السليم السريع على سلاح المهندسين في
مدينه ام درمان كنا طبعا في الساعه
الماضيه كانت هناك انباء تتحدث عن سيط
السريعه لسلاح المهندسين بمدينه ام درمان
الان مصدر عسكري للعربيه ينفي ذلك اذا
لصحه لسيطره الدعم السريع على سلاح
المهندسين بمدينه ام درمان دكتور اعود
اليك دكتور رشيد ابراهيم
هل يمكن يعني بعد كل هذه التصريحات يعني
منذ قليل السيد البرهان تحدث وقياده الجيش
السوداني تتحدث بانه لا حوار في ظل هذا
الانفلات
من قادر الان على وقف هذا الانفراد وخاصه
بانه الطرفان لا يريدان الحوار في هذه
الاثناء
نعم الان العلاج تجاوز الحوار طبعا وتجاوز
التفاوض
بندقيه فلذلك افتكر انه الجيش وحزم امره
واستنادا على التصريحات للناطق الرسمي
وبعض العيادات بانهم ليس هنالك تفاوض قبل
ان يتم دحر هذا التمرد واخراجه من المواقع
الاستراتيجيه النوبات يهدد
هل الجيش برايك سيذهب الى الاخير
لاقصاء الدعم السريع
وجعلوا يتراجع عن كل هذه الاجراءات وكل
هذا التقدم وكل هذه السيطره التي سيطر
عليها لمواقع رسميه
طبعا بمنطقه الجيش الان الدعم السريع هو
قوات متمرده والقوات المتمرده يتم التعامل
معها وفق القانون يعني الذي يعني يحدد
كيفيه التعامل مع هذه القوات والان
الميدان
ويشهد
اجراءات
لاخراج قوات الدعم السريع من كل المناطق
وطبعا القوات الدعم الشريحه قوات عسكريه
وليست حزب سياسي فبالتالي المساله تختلف
لانه التفاوض والتراجع يكون دائما للاحزاب
السياسيه مثل ما حدث
الاحزاب التي قتلت
الرئيس الرئيس الاسبق النميري في 76
الحركه الوطنيه كانت تعامل عسكري وفيه
احزاب كذلك القوات التي دخلت خليل ايضا
كانت عباره عن قوات متمرده يعني فالنماذج
موجوده ولكن تبقى من ناحيه المهنيه ومن
ناحيه الفنيه قبل ان تاخذ دوره الحرب هذه
دورتها يصعب الحديث عن
التفاوض ساعود اليك لنتحدث عن كم من الوقت
من الممكن او نتوقع ان تاخذ وقت حمل او
هذه الجوله العنف الحاصله الان في السودان
ولا اتحدث اكثر عن موضوع القانون الذي اقر
عام 2017 واعتراف بان الدعم السريع هو من
ضمن المؤسسه العسكريه ولكن دعنا نتوقف
الان ايضا مع بعض الاخبار العاجله مجلس
السياده السوداني يقول معظم المنشات
العسكريه والحيويه في البلاد تحت سيطره
الجيش ايضا اريد واذكر بما اتحدث عنه
وزراء خارجيه السعوديه الامارات وامريكا
حيث اكدوا على العوده الى الاتفاق الاطاري
في السودان واكدوا على اهميه وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وكان ذلك خلال اتصال
ثلاثي بين وزراء خارجيه السعوديه الامارات
وامريكا لبحث الاوضاع في السودان ساعود
ايضا واتوقف الان مع موقف وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن الذي دعا جميع
الجهات الفاعله في السودان لوقف العنف
فورا وتجنب المزيد من التصعيد ومواصله
المفاوضات لحل القضايا العالقه كما عبر عن
بالغي قلقه ازاء تصاعد العنف بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
هذه المواقف كانت دوليا ولكن داخليا ايضا
اكد رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك بان الحل السلمي في البلاد لا
يزال ممكنا حيث دعا الاطراف العسكريه
المتحاربه الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
والجلوس على الطاوله الحوار نستمع يجب ان
يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع ولا يوجد
منتصر على جثث شعبي رساله ثانيه للشعب
السوداني بان ازداد تماسكا وان يكون تلاحم
ومكونات المجتمع وخطاب رفض الاحتراب
والسعيد وان لا يتم السماح لصوت اذكى
الحرب بالسيطره رساله الثالثه المجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي ومحبي السلام العالمي
بان يقوموا بواجبهم في الحل وتهدئه
الاطراف المتقاتله فالحرب في السودان تعني
الحرب في الاقليم
ولا يزال الحل السلمي ممكنا
والان صحيفه السوداني تتحدث عن مقتل خمسه
مدنيين جراء الاشتباكات في نيالا جنوب
دارفور اذا صحيفه السوداني تتحدث عن مقتل
خمس مدنيين جراء الاشتباكات في نيالا جنوب
دارفور ونعود ونذكر بانه لا احصائيات او
ارقام رسميه حول المدنيين الذين سقطوا
اليوم او عدد الجرحى وطبعا بالنسبه
للعسكريين من الطرفين لا معلومات واساسا
المؤسسه العسكريه لا تعطي دائما ارقام
ضحايا اذا كان هناك من ضحايا او لجرحى على
كل حال اعود الى ضيوفي من الخرطومه دكتور
الرشيد ابراهيم وايضا رئيس لجنه السياسات
في حزب الامه القومي امام الحلو استاذ
امام قمت اتحدث قبل ان اتوقف مع هذه
الاخبار العاجله وبعض المواقف الدوليه
والداخليه تجاه هذا التصعيد داخل السودان
تحدثت مع دكتور رشيد ابراهيم
عن موضوع هذا الصراع بين مكونين ينتمون
الى المؤسسه العسكريه لانه من المعلوم
بانه الدعم السريع عام 2017 من خلال قانون
اصبح جزء من هذه
المؤسسه العسكريه فكيف يمكن التعاطي معها
الان مع اساس افراد او عسكر متمرد او
ميليشيات او يعني هناك الكثير من الصفات
التي اطلقت عليها اليوم
استاذ امام هل تسمعني
يبدو باننا فقدنا استاذ امام
ساذهب اليك مجددا دكتور رشيد كيف يمكن ان
نتعامل مع الدعم السريع على اساس بانها
حركه متمرده او ميليشيات وهي من ضمن او
فصين من هذه المؤسسه العسكريه
رغم الفصائل في داخل الجيوش الواحده ايضا
تستمر يعني السودان له قصه مع هذا التمرد
او التمرد كان لكتيبه في توريد في العام
فالكتائب تتمرد حتى لو كانت في الجيش
السوداني يعني ناهيك من قوات خليفه او
منشاه بقانون قوات الدعم السريع فهذا هو
هذا الحال
هنالك متغير مهم جدا اصرار الجيش الان على
حسم هذا التمرد والى اعاده توازن القوى
ووضع الامور الى نصابها
اعلنه الناطق الرسمي هذا ابشر بان هنالك
واقعا سياسيا ومعادله جديده في المشهد
السوداني قد تغير من الخطاب القديم وقد
تؤسس ربما لتغيرات جديده لانه قضيه الدمج
لن تكون هنالك موجوده يعني اذا ما تم حسم
التمرد الدعم السريع وتتركون
من السهوله حسم موضوع الدعم السريعي لماذا
تقصد بكلمه حسم هل من الممكن ان هل من
الممكن استبعاد الدعم السريع من الجيش هل
من الممكن استبعاد سيد حميتي من الحكم
العسكري نعم هي ليست بسهوله ولكنها ايضا
غير مستحيله تماما يعني الان ما يحصل
العدوان وما يحصل هو تمرد
التعامل معه عسكريا بعني هزيمته وعسكريا
وان هزم عسكريا فهي قوات عسكريه طبعا
وليست قوات سياسيه ستفقد ميزه ان يكون لها
ادوار الطبيعه المستقبليه هي ليس مثلها
مثل حركه عبد العزيز الحلو او حركه عبد
الواحد محمد نوره الوضع المختلف ولذلك يجب
ان ان نقرا المشهد بصوره طائره تماما
الحديث طبعا عن العمليه السياسيه انا
افتكر انه الوقت مبكر
لتحديد مستقبل العمليه السياسيه ولكن مبت
نقول ان التغييرات هذه سوف تحدث واقرا
سياسيا وعسكريا جديدا ربما يستدعي مراجعات
داخليه بالنسبه للقوه السياسيه وحتى للقوه
الخارجيه في منهج ادارتها للازمه
السودانيه اتوقع ان يطول
للدكتور رشيد هل هل هذا واقعي هذه النظره
هل هي واقعيه هل من الممكن ان يسمح الدعم
السريع
بهذه السهوله ان يتخلى عن كل المكتسبات
التي حصل عليها خلال هذه السنوات الماضيه
الدعم السريع عمليا تخلى عن كل المكتسبات
عندما
يعني تصرف بصوره فرديه ويقول انه يتبع
للجيش تدعيه للجيش
كيف تتبع للجيش وانت تحرك اليات بدون
تنسيق مع الجيش بدون اوامر تحرك من الجيش
فتنقل اليات مع الجيش فهو بهذه الخطوه
انما هو صنف نفسه وانا اقول ان هنالك
تقديرات خاطئه لقوات الدعم السريع او
اقعدته في هذا الموقع قطعا يعني بعد انتاج
العمليه لن يكون حميتيه في مجلس السياده
ولا نائبا لرئيس المجلس السياده
نتابع سويا هذه الصور المتداوله لاستسلام
عناصر من قوات الدعم السريع فني للازرق
دعم السريع
والله هاربين
قبلناهم ودي عرباته
ودام وعسكرهم الدمازين والحمد لله
اكبر والعزه للسودان
السلام عليكم الحمد لله التمازين امنه
استلمنا الدعم السريع
والله هاربين
وغاداتهم قبلناهم ودي عرباته
وداموا عسكرهم الدمازين والحمد لله
اكبر والعزه للسودان
دكتور رشيد اعود اليك نتحدث عن الدعم
السريع تتحدث حضرتك عن الحسم يبدو باننا
ايضا فقدنا الاتصال بالدكتور رشيد ابراهيم
ولكن استاذ امام الحلو اصبح معي مجددا
استاذ امام هل تسمعني مرحبا مرحبا
استاذ امام كان دكتور رشيد يقول بانه من
الممكن ان يكون هناك حسم لهذه المعركه
بانه لا نرى السيد حميدتي متواجد في
المجلس السيادي ولا ان يكون نائبا الى اي
حد هذه النظره واقعيه ومن الممكن ان تحصل
وما هو ثمنها
طبعا هذا موقف غير شريف
نحن
نتعامل مع المؤسسه العسكريه طبعا
الدعم السريع وافق
بالاتفاق الايطالي على دمج قوات الدعم
السريع وتكوين جيش وطني مهني بعقيده
عسكريه جديده متفق عليهم والان اي حديث عن
امر الله في يعني خلافات غير كده بنتيجه
المواجهه العسكريه الحاليه ونحن ندعو الى
وقت هذا التفعي كان اعلامي او عسكري
والمواجهات دي ما فيها منتصر الخاشر هو
الشعب السوداني الخاص هو السلب الخاسر هي
المنطقه كلها طب المؤشرات استاذ امام
المؤشرات تتحدث بانه يبدو ان التصعيد
سيقيد الموقف هل نتوقع نحن نكون امام يعني
البعض يعتبرها اشتباكات وتصعيد بين
الطرفين والبعض الاخر اصبح يسميها حرب
طبعا قد يكون في اطراف في مصلحته
هذا الموقف الدامي ولكن الشعب السوداني
وقوه الحيه وقوه الثوره ترفض هذا المواجهه
العسكريه بين نحن على يعني حوار معهم اصلا
منذ فتره طويله عبر العمليه سياسيه لانهاء
هذا الوضع
استاذ امام انكم ترفضون ذلك وان تكونوا
قادرين على وقف هذا العنف لانكن انتم لستم
طرفا فيه
نعم نعم صحيح ونحن سعيد وطبعا كما انت
شايفه الان من المشاهد
المشاهد في كل اغلب مدن السودان الان صوت
الرصاص والدانات هو العالي صحيح
وليس فقط رصاص
نعم صحيح
في كل المناطق الخر
نحن ندعو
عيادات
الطرفين
لمال الحكمه والمصلحه الوطنيه وتغليف
السلام لانه هم الاثنين
وقعوا اتفاقيه كلام مع الحركات المسلحه
والمفترض انه هم اولى بدعم السلام ولذلك
صحيح الان الان في هذه اللحظات
صوت الحكمه صعب ولكن نحن في حزب الامه وفي
الحريه والتغيير والقوه لموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي سعيد
بشق السبل
الطرق الشعبيه اللي عندنا والعلاقات
الاجتماعيه للتواصل مع قيادات القوات من
الطرفين على الاقل لوقف اطلاق النار الان
وننتقل الى مرحله اخرى عبر
مشتركه وده اللي ورد فيه بيان حزب الامه
اليوم الصباح في انه تشكيل لينه مشتركه من
الطرفين مع شخصيات قوميه معروفه في
بتوازنك البلد استاذ امام لنتحدث اكثر عن
هذه المبادره وعن هذه اللجنه وتعطينا
تفاصيل او عنها ويبدو ايضا دكتور رشيد
ايضا اصبح معنا مجددا ولكن اسمحوا لي ان
نتابع مقاطع الفيديو هذه التي اظهرت قصفا
جويا في سماء العاصمه في اطار الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ايضا دارت الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الرئاسي ووزاره الدفاع بطائرات ميج 29
نتابع
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو اخر تم تداوله عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي اظهر دخول قوات الدعم
السريع وسيطرتها على قياده اللواء الاول
مشاه للقوات البريه السودانيه
من قياده اللواء الاول انشاء الي للقوات
البريه
[تصفيق]
في القياده كامله لغه في قبضتنا تماما
تمام
وهديك كروزراتهم
الدبابات
مقدما عفن الزمان بيقولوها
دبابات دبابات سودانيه
الحمد لله الرجال اشتغلوا ابشروا بالخير
ابشروا بالخير رياده اللواء الاول مشاه
الي رواد البريه
اعود مجددا الى ضيفي امام الحلو رئيس لجنه
السياسات في حزب الامه القوميه وايضا
دكتور رشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في مركز العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم
اعود واجدد تحياتي اليكما والان هناك
اخبار عاجله على شاشه العربيه قائد قوات
الدعم السريع للعربيه يقول ادير العمليات
العسكريه من الخرطوم وبانهم لم ينسحبوا من
مواقعهم وبانهم مستمرون بالقتال دكتور
رشيد ابراهيم اعود اليك بعد هذه التصريحات
وكان هناك ايضا تصريحات للجيش السوداني
بانه لا حوار في ظل هذا الانفلات الامني
وفي ظل هذا التصعيد الامور يبدو اي
للتصعيد ولكن هل نتحدث نحن عن ايام طويله
هل ستمتد لاشهر ام امام اي مشهد السودان
سيكون
يواجه في الايام المقبله
نعم نحن ايام ايام غلائل كايام رمضان يعني
وكذلك هي مواجهه محدوده وليست مواجهه
واحده والدليل على ذلك ان مواجهات اليوم
يعني بالرغم ما تم فيها من انها استهدفت
رئاسه الدعم السريع
ومناطق تواجدها وتمركزه في المواقع التي
سيطر عليها بعض سقوط وحل هيئه العمليات في
طيبه وفي شمبات وفي كالوري وشرق النيل
ولكن رغم كل هذا العمل العسكري الكبير
ولكن
الضحايا
وعدد القتلى من المدنيين هو بسيط طبعا لا
لا يعني ذلك اننا نستخف لان نفس الواحده
كانما هي يعني الناس جميعا ولكن غياثا على
المواجهات التي تحدث في دول ومناطق اخرى
افتكر انه هنالك
غدر من الانضباط ومبدا يمارس الان في
العمليه يبالغ
يبالغ طبعا لانه
الحرب الاهليه في السودان غير وارده الان
ليس الانقسام هو انقسام اهلي وانغام سياسي
والانقسام السياسي دائما لا يكون على اساس
القبيله او الوحده يعني على ما هو حادث
يعني او في جنوب السودان بين النويره او
بين في تشاد وافريغ الوسط وقطعا المساله
تختلف السودان ليس غريبا من اي ما حرب
اهليه
لاسباب انه الصراع ليس اسمي ولا يعتمد على
القبيله وليس من الصراعات الاجتماعيه
المتاصله التي يصنفها علماء النزاعات
بانها تاخذ وقت كبير يعني
من ذلك حتى الان دكتور وانت تتحدث معي
قائد قوات الدعم السريه سيد حميدتي يتحدث
العربيه ويقول بان الحرب كرب ولا سيطره
للجيش حتى الان
هذا الحديث يفهم في سياق رفع معنويات
قواته وهذا واجبه كغايه طبعا لا يسر
الاستسلام ويبدو بانه يحمل المسؤوليه
للجيش من خلال تصريحاته لانه ايضا يقول
الان للعربيه بان الجيش حاصر معسكراتهم ما
طرهم للرد اذا حسب قائد قوات الدعم السريع
في تصريحات للعربيه يقول بان الجيش حاصر
معسكراتنا مضطرنا للرد
نعم انا افهم
تصريحات وحديث
الفريقيه يعني في اطار العمليه التي تجري
الان وانه تعرض يعني
في كل معسكراته يعني معسكر الصالحه ومعسكر
الطيبه واخليه معسكري يعني المساله انا
افهمها لاني حاضر ومتابع ومشاهد يعني ايضا
يؤكد الان السيد حميدتي للعربيه بان قوات
الدعم السريع ملتزمه بامن وسلامه
العسكريين المصريين اذا قائد قوات الدعم
السريع للعربيه يتحدث عن التزامهم بامن
وسلامه العسكريين المصريين طبعا هناك
تواجد لعسكريين مصريين في قاعده عسكريه في
مروي وايضا كانت قوات الدعم السريع تواجدت
فيها وكانت هي الشراره حقيقه لبدايه هذا
التصعيد اعود اليك
استاذ امام سمعت الان بعض التصريحات لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع للعربيه يبدو بان نحن
امام مواجهه مستمره
نعم انا الحقيقه اتعجب من يعني حديث ضيفه
الكريمه وكانما هو سعيد بهذا التضعيف
وسعيد لهذه الدماء وكيف يقول ان الضحايا
المدنيين عدد قليل
[موسيقى]
هو هو يقول
في حديثه
اكد هذا الكلام بانك ترفض هذا الحدث جمله
وتفصيلا نحن في القوه السياسيه المدنيه
نرفض هذه الحرب اللعينه ونرفض هذه
المواجهات بين ابناء الوطن الواحد
استاذ امام دانه نسمع دعنا نسمع دكتور
رشيد بماذا يرد
ليس هنالك سوداني الان سعيد بهذه الحرب
على القوه السياسيه
طالب
الكل يطالب والكل ضد الغرب
ضد العنف ولكن نحن
نتحدثها ونحللها ادوات التحليل السياسي
وليس بالعواطف وليس بالاهواء نحن في شهر
كل الاطراف دكتور رشيد وايضا استاذ
نحن نريد ان نفصل ونشرح ما يحدث في
السودان ولكن دعوني ايضا اذكر بالاخبار
العاجله التي وردت على شاشه العربيه وهي
تصريحات لقائد قوات الدعم السريع للعربيه
حيث قال بانه يق الوصفات الدوليه والعربيه
والاحزاب السياسيه السودانيه قال لا حوار
قبل تراجع الجيش السوداني ونتعامل مع
الجنود المصريين كاخوه ونعمل على اخلائهم
سريعا كما قال بانهم ملتزمون بامن وسلامه
العسكريين المصريين وبان الجيش حاصر
معسكراتهم مضطرهم للرد وبان الحرب كروه
فروله سيطره للجيش حتى الانوا بانه يدير
العمليات العسكريه من الخرطوم هذه ابرز
التصريحات لسيد حميدتي للعربيه حول هذه
التطورات الحاصله في السودان اشكرك من
الخرطوم دكتور رشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه في مركز العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم كما اشكر ضيفنا
من الخرطوم ايضا امام الحلو رئيس لجنه
السياسات في حزب الامه القوميه
ساذهب الان الى مروي لينضم الينا مراسل
عربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا
الوضع لديك فيما روى
داخل هذه المدينه مروي الهدوء هو السيد
الموقف على الرغم من ان هذا اليوم بدا
عصيبا وبدا متوترا وبدا باطلاق النار وذوي
الغاذفات والمدفعيه الثقيله عندما استمع
اليها المواطنون في الساعه التاسعه من
صباح هذا اليوم واستمرت حتى الخامسه او
السادسه من مساء هذا اليوم وتوقفت بعض
افطار رمضان
الجيش السوداني وحسب المصادر وحسب
المعلومات يتحدث عن استعداده لاسوء
السيناريوهات وانه يرتب نفسه الان ويعيد
الانتشار ويعيد التمركز داخل قاعده مروي
العسكريه وخارج هذه القاعده ويقول بان بعض
قوات وعناصر الدعم السريع ما زالت متمركزه
وموجوده داخل هذه القاعده اعداد الجرحى
داخل صفوف الجيش السوداني هي الان ما بين
30 الى 45 وفي حدود الخمسين هذه هي
المعلومات الاوليه حتى الان حصر الضحايا
بصوره اجماليه بصوره كليه وعدد المركبات
وعدد الاليات التي دمرت وان كان من طائرات
حربيه ايضا دمرت في القاعده هذا الامر
ايضا ننتظر بيان مفصلي [__] حصيله ضحايا
واضرار اليوم الاول وكثيرون يتمنون ان لا
يكون هنالك يوم ثاني لهذا الاشتباكات التي
تنوعت ووصلت الى مرحله العمليه العسكريه
وهنالك من يتحدث عن حرب اذا ما اشرنا الى
امتدادها هنا في مروي وفي الخرطوم وفي عدد
من مدن ومواقع السودان بالنسبه للمدنيين
كانت هناك بعض الصور توضح وكانه بعض
الاشخاص يخرجون من منازلهم ويتوجهون الى
مناطق اكثر اما داخل المدينه هل يمكن
اعتبار هذا هناك عمليات نزوح ام هي مقتصره
على بعض الافراد تخوفا مما يجري في مروره
يعني كان حزينا بالنسبه لي بصوره شخصيه
خروج تلاميذ وتلميذات وطالبات من احدى
المدارس عندما استمعن الى صوت الدواء
المدرعات والاليات الثقيله هرول وجرين
هنالك من تعثرت ووقعت على الارض عندما
استمعت الى صوت الذخيره ربما تستمع اليها
لاول مره خرجنا مهرولات من المدرسه صوب
البيوت ومن بالبيوت خرج من المنازل صوب
عمق المدينه ليحتمي مع الاهل ومع الاقارب
المواطنون الان جزعون يتخوفون من
سيناريوهات اليوم الاول ولا يتوقعون ان
تمضي الامور كما كانت من قبل هادئه مستقره
خاصه وان الجيش الان كما ذكرنا قال بانه
يستعد لاسوء السيناريوهات وحاله الترقب هي
ما زالت حاضره الان مدينه مروي التي نتحدث
منها هي مدينه هادئه تطبق عليها حاله
التوتر المقر الرسميه الان مغلقه بالكامل
المقاهي مغل السوق الكبير سوق المدينه
الرئيس مغلق بالكامل الشوارع مظلمه لا
حركه للسيارات لا حركه للمواطنين الكره
الان في منزله يتابع عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ما يرشح من اخبار يتابعون
القنوات الاخباريه ليعرفوا مستجدات هذه
العمليه العسكريه هنا في مروي وفي مختلف
مدن السودان بالتالي الان هم يتابعون
ويتخوفون ويتمنون اقول ذلك يتمنون ان لا
تعيش مروي ذات اللحظات العصيبه التي
عاشتها خلال اكثر من عشر ساعات خلال هذا
اليوم اذا حسب زميلنا نزار بداوي الاوضاع
الان هادئه في مروي وهناك حاله ترقب لما
يمكن ان يحصل نعود ونذكر بان هناك تصريحات
لقائد قوات دعم السريع للعربيه تحدث فيها
بانه ما زال يدير هذه العمليات وبان
العمليات هي حاله كر وفر هذه التغطيه ما
زالت مستمره ولكن ننتقل الان الى زميلتنا
راويه عالمي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات